hi there everyone today's video is going
to be a super deep technical dive on all
of the different settings in BL heli 32
I've been doing some exhaustive testing
on some larger and some smaller Motors
and in this video I'm going to be
showing you all of the results I'm going
to be taking you through what all of the
different settings do and how you can
use them to tune your ESC to get the
best possible performance at the very
end I'm going to be giving you my ESC
setting recommendations so that you can
get your ESC tuned to Perfection and get
the most performance out of it it's a
lot to cover in one video so let's not
waste any more time let's dive right
into it if you'd like access to all of
this information and my ESC tuning
recommendations in a handy quick
reference guide in PDF format then
that's available on my patreon if you
sign up you'll also be the first to see
my upcoming ESC tuning recommendations
for tiny whoops and larger 7 and 8 in
Motors as well there are links to all of
that down in the video description
before we dive into the test data I want
to take you through what we're going to
be testing today starting with the
motors we're going to be testing two
Motors the first is a big powerful 5in
motor with 14 magnets and 12 coils so
this is the AOS Supernova 20207 and it's
the most powerful highest performing
5-in motor that I've ever
tested for a smaller motor we have this
Sky Stars 1404 this is a 3-in motor it's
only got 12 magnets so it's got fewer
magnets than the Supernova and only nine
coils rather than 12 so this is a very
different motor configuration it's much
more popular among the smaller sizes and
this Sky starles motor is the best 1404
motor that I've ever tested so it's a
very good candidate for this type of ESC
testing we're going to be using some
test props and some fly wheels to do the
testing so we've got a 5in test prop the
HQ 5x 4.5 by3 v1s it's my standard test
prop for 5in Motors and for the 3in we
have this hqt 3x3x3 test prop again
that's my standard test prop for 3in
Motors we also going to be doing some
flywheel tests for the 5-in motor we're
going to be using this 100 kg mm squ
aluminium flywheel and for the smaller
404 motor we have this 10 kg mm squ
flywheel now that we've covered the
hardware that we're going to be testing
it's time to look at the software and
we're going to be using BL heli suet 32
to change the settings on our BL heli 32
ESC and unit to give the best possible
performance there are three key settings
that affect ESC performance that we're
going to be looking at today the first
is ramp up power ramp up power controls
how quickly the ESC increases the power
delivered to the motor as the motor
accelerates and increases in RPM it can
be adjusted from 3% all the way up to
150% having too little ramp up power
tends to cause Motors to struggle to
start and can also limit how quickly a
motor can accelerate can reduce its
responsiveness
conversely having too much ramp up power
dumps current into the motor when it's
still spinning at a relatively low RPM
and that doesn't produce any more torque
because the motor is fundamentally
limited by its maximum mechanical torque
but all that extra current does cause a
lot of motor heating so you can get very
hot Motors if your ramp up power is set
too high the optimum amount of ramp up
power is going to be the minimum amount
that still gives you the maximum motor
acceleration the second setting we're
going to look at is motor timing motor
timing controls when during the rotation
of the motor Bell the coils are
activated to drive the the rotor round
it can be adjusted from 1° all the way
up to 31° and there is also an auto
setting having a timing that's too low
will limit the maximum torque and power
of the motor particularly at high RPMs
because the coil won't have time to
activate before the rotor has sort of
swung past it having too much timing
will increase torque and power but will
also increase motor heating so similar
to ramp up power the optimum timing is
the minimal amount of timing the
smallest amount that still gives you the
maximum torque and power from the motor
the final setting we're going to be
looking at is the pwm frequency and this
is adjustable from 16 khz on the low end
all the way up to 128 khz on the high
end and there is also a by RPM setting
as well so so we're going to be talking
about that later it's not clear to me
what the optimal pwm frequency should be
so we're going to be testing a whole
heap of them there's some evidence that
high pwm frequencies improve efficiency
for very small motors and I've certainly
seen in my testing before that high pwm
frequencies can reduce the braking
torque of Motors reduces how quickly
they slow down and that can negatively
affect the responsiveness of the Quad so
we're going to be testing a whole heap
of different pwm frequencies on both
this five in and 3-in motor and seeing
what the optimum is for each of those
configurations there are of course lots
of other settings on this panel but
we're not going to be talking about them
too much today because none of them have
a measurable effect on Motor Performance
and that includes P modulation mode
which I did test but didn't have any
measurable impact on Motor Performance
on either the 5 or the 3-in motor let's
look first at rampup Power and here
we're measuring ramp up power on our 5in
Supernova motor and the HQ 5x4 4.5x 3
prop I'm testing this with 16° of timing
and 24 khz pwm which is the default for
BL heli 32 and we're measuring the rate
of acceleration of the motor using the
data from bidirectional dshot captured
on my thrust test stand which is the
best way I found to measure the
acceleration of the motor what we can
see is that at very low ramp up powers
like 6% the motor does accelerate a
little more slowly with the prop on
compared to with higher ramp up power
settings but we don't see any difference
in acceleration above about 10% ramp up
power but from my testing I can tell you
that as you increase the ramp up power
above 10% the motor does get slightly
warmer um with each test when you
increase that ramp up power so there's
no benefit as it were to running a
higher ramp up power than 10% but the
motor does get hotter as a result
obviously you might not be running
exactly the same motor as this on
exactly the same ESC and it's always
better to have slightly more ramp up
power than slightly less so I would
recommend 30% ramp up power as a pretty
conservative setting for a high-powered
5-in motor like this if we look now at
deceleration you can see that ramp up
power has absolutely no effect on the
deceleration of the motor whatsoever so
we don't have to consider deceleration
when thinking about rampup power I also
did some tests with a flywheel and a
flywheel test is I guess it's a
different type of acceler ation test
because the mass is much larger and the
motor accelerates much more slowly here
it's taking seconds to accelerate rather
than milliseconds and in this case
there's really no difference based on
ramp up power at all the one thing I
will say is that having the ramp up
power set really low but 3% did prevent
the motor from starting in all the tests
so you can't have ramp up power too low
otherwise the motor simply won't start
spinning with the 3-in motor I saw a
much bigger influence of ramp up power
on the acceleration of the motor here we
can see that at 6% and 10% the motor is
accelerating more slowly than it is at
higher ramp up powers and that we don't
see much difference in acceleration
above about 20 to 30% ramp up power or
so at 3% ramp up the motor was again
unable to start and based on this
information I would recommend that for a
3-in motor if you've got a slightly
different motor a slightly different ESC
a 50% ramp up power setting is going to
be very conservative it's going to make
sure that you're achieving Max Maxum
motor acceleration without getting too
much heating exactly the same as with
the 5in motors I didn't see any
influence of ramp up power on the
deceleration of the motor so you don't
need to worry about ramp up power when
considering how fast the motor is able
to decelerate I also did a flywheel test
on the motor and again this actually
showed quite similar results to what I
saw with the prop testing despite the
acceleration being a lot slower um at 6%
and 10% ramp up power the motor
acceleration was reduced and also
perhaps just a little bit of 20% but
once you get up to 30% ramp up power
that's the maximum motor acceleration
and increasing ramp up power beyond that
didn't give any additional benefit but
again it did get the motor slightly
hotter as I said before a 50% ramp up
power setting should be really
conservative for most 3-in Motors and
esc's now let's look at motor timing and
one of the first things I noticed when
changing the the timing of the ESC was
its effect on the measured KV of the
motor you can see the increase in the
timing significantly increases the
measured KV of the motor and I measure
KV by driving the motor Full Throttle at
10 volts and then dividing the RPM the
motor achieves by 10 to get the KV in
RPM per volt and you can see that
increasing the timing from 8 to 31°
increases the KV by more than 100 KV so
it does have a big impact on KV and that
the auto timing setting has pretty much
the same KV as the 16° of
timing the same effect is true on the
3-in motor increasing the timing also
increases the KV and again it's by a
significant amount it's about 200 KV in
this
case when we're looking at the timing
versus the responses of the motor with
the test prop we can see that increase
in the timing very slightly increases
the responsiveness of the motor the rate
of acceleration of the motor for the 5-
in supernova
I did notice that large timings 31° also
slightly increased the motor heating
during the responsiveness test so I
could feel a difference in the
temperature of the motor with a larger
timing looking at the 3-in motor and the
responsiveness the difference is a lot
bigger we can see that with 8 degrees of
timing the motor really struggles to
accelerate and then as we increase the
timing to 16 and then 24° we see big
improvements in motor responsiveness but
once we get to 24° we don't see any
further Improvement by increasing the
timing to 31° like we saw with the 5-in
Supernova with this smaller motor
there's just no benefit Beyond 24° and
it might be due to the difference in
pole count the 3-in motor has 12 poles
with nine coils whereas the larger 5-in
Supernova motor has 14 poles and 12
coils so that difference in Geometry
difference in the number of coils might
affect the Optimum timing to use on the
motor if we're looking at deceleration
we can see that for the 5-in motor
timing really has no or very very little
effect on the deceleration of the motor
the 31° of timing does seem to
decelerate very slightly slower than the
others but the effect is very very
marginal if we look at the 3-in motor
the effective timing is a little bit
more pronounced we see that the 31° of
timing is the slowest to decelerate and
then the 16° of timing is
slightly better but Auto and 24 degre of
timing give the best result
and again the effect is pretty marginal
here but 24° of timing again seems to be
the best for the 3-in
motor if we're looking at efficiency for
the 5-in Supernova motor motor timing
had very little effect on efficiency uh
we got pretty much the same amount of
thrust at the same amount of electrical
power no matter what timings we used um
possibly you could say that the 24 and
31° of timing had some advantages
particularly at those higher power
levels and then the lower timing sort of
16° or so has a slight Advantage at the
lower power levels and that corresponds
with what I've seen in previous testing
when you're just cruising around you
might want to argue that having the 16°
of timing will give you the best overall
efficiency if you're looking more for
topend power and efficiency at high
throttle then you could definitely argue
that a slightly higher timing maybe 24
degre gives a small benefit but it's
pretty
marginal if we look at the 3-in motor
the effects are a little bit bigger here
we see that the auto timing Falls
slightly behind the rest in terms of
efficiency and the fixed timings do
quite a bit better between the fixed
timings definitely the 8 degrees of
timing is the worst and then there's
very very little difference between 16
24 and 31° of timing in terms of
efficiency
looking at top end thrust and power now
we can see that the 24° and 31° of
timing on the 5-in Supernova motor
provide slightly more top end thrust
than the other options so you're getting
a little bit more power a little bit
more thrust at Full Throttle by
increasing the timing to 24 or
31° for the 3-in motor we see slightly
different result here 16° and 24° of
timing provide the maximum thrust and
then as we go to 31° actually the
maximum thrust Falls away a little bit
and this again corresponds with the
motor response that is not really
improving at 31° of timing it seems that
for that smaller 3-in motor more than
24° of timing just doesn't offer any
benefit anymore now that we have all
that data I think we can give some good
recommendations on what the best timing
settings are for 5-in and 3-in motors I
think if you're running a 5-in motor and
you're just wanting to cruise around and
have the best efficiency then 16° of
timing is probably the best choice if
you're looking for the maximum top end
power and you're looking for efficiency
higher in the throttle then certainly
you could consider increasing that
timing to 24° and it's not going to give
you much impact in terms of motor
heating but you will get a little bit
more topend power if however you're
running a 3-in motor with 12 poles and
nine coils then it's definitely worth
increasing that timing to 24° because
you see benefits in significant benefits
in responsiveness efficiency and top end
thrust and power so definitely worth
going for 24° on a 3-in motor the final
setting is probably the one that I'm
asked the most about which is pwm
frequency and here we're looking at pwm
frequency versus the acceleration of a
prop with the 5-in Supernova motor and
we can see that there is very little
difference in acceleration regardless of
pwm setting apart from 128 khz so that
super high pwm frequency does seem to
significantly reduce the acceleration of
the motor all of the other pwm settings
have very similar accelerations and you
could say there might be a slight Edge
to either the 32 khz or the 48 khz at
low
RPMs and maybe 96 khz is doing a bit
better at higher RPMs it all of these
differences are very marginal
what is very interesting though is when
we look at the 3-in motor is that
there's actually a much bigger
difference higher pwm frequencies on
that smaller motor with smaller coils
lower
inductance really did not accelerate
anywhere near as well as the lower pwm
frequencies and in fact above 48 khz
testing 96 and
128k the motor wouldn't even accelerate
at all it didn't accelerate cleanly it
kind of I could hear it jerking and
sometimes it would fail to accelerate so
for smaller motors for 3in size motors
pwm frequency has a much bigger impact
than on a larger 5in motor that's
probably due to the different inductance
of the motor coils needless to say the
16 and 24 khz pwm were the fastest
accelerating and then as we moved to 32
and 48 khz the rate of acceleration
really
reduced looking at deceleration PW M
frequency has always had a huge effect
on motor breaking with increasing pwm
frequency reducing the strength of motor
breaking and we see that again with the
5-in Supernova motor as we increase that
pwm frequency the motor decelerates more
and more slowly and it's actually really
audible when you get up to those higher
pwm frequencies that the motor is taking
a long time to spin down after it's
accelerated based on this you can't
really recommend running a fixed PM
frequency
much higher than about 48 khz because of
that huge impact on motor
breaking if we're looking at the 3in
motor we see the same effect the uh
higher the pwm frequency the slower the
motor is decelerating unfortunately I
don't have data for 96 or 128k here
because as I said before the motor
really struggled to actually accelerate
cleanly with those pwm settings so I
couldn't get a clean test but for the
pwm settings that we do have we can see
the same Trend as we saw with the 5-in
motor higher pwm frequency worse
breaking performance now let's look at
pwm versus efficiency for the 5-in
Supernova motor and it's often been
stated that a higher pwm frequency
increases the efficiency of the ESC and
increases the efficiency of the motor um
we don't see a strong effect of this on
these these test results motor pwm here
has a pretty small effect on on
efficiency we do see that increasing the
pwm frequency slightly does help
increase efficiency initially so there's
definitely an improvement from 16 khz
pwm to 24 khz pwm but beyond that we see
very very little benefit an increasing
PW pwm frequency more and more doesn't
give you greater and greater
improvements in motor
efficiency looking now at the 3-in motor
we see very very similar results
increasing pwm frequency has a small
benefit icial effect on efficiency
initially when we go from 16 to 24K but
then the improvements are non-existent
above 24K we don't see much benefit at
all increasing that pwm frequency higher
and higher past 24 khz looking at pwm
versus thrust for the 5-in Supernova we
see that pwm frequency has very little
effect on top end thrust and power the
ESC is not even switching when you're at
Full Throttle it's just fully on fully
off so it's not surprising that we don't
see any effect of pwm frequency pwm
frequency does have a small effect on
the throttle curve um increasing the pwm
frequency does can sort of give you a
slightly different shape throttle curve
but this effect is pretty marginal and
you probably wouldn't even notice it
that top end thrust and power though is
identical no matter what pwm frequency
you're
setting the same is pretty much true for
the 3-in motor again we see very very
small differences very little difference
at the very top end in terms of thrust
and power again the ESC is not switching
we do see slightly different shaped
throttle curves and you could argue that
uh there
is the throttle curve for the higher PM
frequencies are slightly steeper than
for the lower PM frequencies but again
this is a pretty marginal effect and
even though you've got that steeper
throttle curve once you get up to the
peak throttle they're all very similar
looking through all this data we can
make some pretty clear recommendations
for pwm frequency for both 5 in and 3-in
motors and in both cases I would
recommend 24 khz as a sweet spot for pwm
frequency it has the best balance of
motor responsiveness and also efficiency
if you go to 16 khz you can get a little
bit more responsiveness but at the cost
of some efficiency and 24 khz gives you
the the kind of the best balance The
Best of Both Worlds if we're talking
about PW frequency we have to mention
the variable pwm options in BL heli 32
for example you can set your pwm
frequency low to 24K and your pwm
frequency High to something else let's
say
48k and what that will do is it will
linearly change your pwm frequency with
your throttle position so if you're at
zero throttle you'll have 24K pwm and as
you increase to Full Throttle that pwm
frequency will rise to
48k in my testing this doesn't offer a
lot of benefit there isn't much benefit
of higher pwm frequencies at higher
throttle positions so variable pwm
doesn't offer much benefit however there
is also a by RPM function and this can
offer some nice benefits if you're
increasing the throttle and you find
that the the throttle sort of gets stuck
or there's a kind of jumpiness in the
throttle at a certain point as you're
increasing the throttle that could be
due to the pwm frequency matching up
with the commutation fre frequency and
when that happens the throttle response
can get a bit
notchy what brpm does is it increases
the pwm frequency with increasing motor
RPM to keep the pwm frequency away from
the commutation frequency and avoid any
naess now I don't notice this with my
quads I always run 24K 24K fixed pwm but
if you are noticing a bit of Notch in
the throttle during slow throttle ramps
then definitely try change ing to the
buy RPM setting the pwm frequency
doesn't rise all that much it only rises
from about 24K to maybe 40 khz maximum
so you're still within that low
frequency pwm range where you get good
breaking good responsiveness uh and good
efficiency all of that stuff just might
help fix a notchy throttle I hope you
enjoyed this video and that these
recommendations will help you get your
BL heli 32 ESC tuned to Perfection don't
forget you can get all the information
and my recommendations in PDF format on
my patreon and if you sign up you'll
also be the first to hear about my
upcoming recommendations for tiny whoop
esc's and esc's for larger 7 and 8 in
Motors as well don't miss out there are
links down in the video description
that's all I have for you for today so
until next time I wish you all very very
happy flying
[Music]